because today is a day that ends in Y we
have another race hoax another hate hoax
this one two days after we were told
that the NASCAR is completely racist yes
that's right the most popular race car
company in the country is full of a
bunch of Klansmen they found a noose a
threatening noose by the car of Bubba
Wallace a racecar driver who just
happened to be wearing a t-shirt that
supported black lives matter and after
an FBI investigation I kid you not they
brought the FBI in on this turns out it
was all completely fake ask her released
a statement the FBI is completed its
investigation at Talladega Superspeedway
and determined that Bubba Wallace was
not the target of a hate crime the FBI
report concludes photographic evidence
confirms that the garage-door pull rope
fashioned like a noose had been
positioned there since as early as last
fall we appreciate the FBI's quick and
thorough investigation we didn't need
the investigation any reasonable person
knew immediately that this was
completely fake and yet the people keep
pretending that it's real what is this
about is it just NASCAR is it just the
media is it just entertainment no it's
all of it it's liberalism itself
liberalism which must constantly be
overcoming the oppressive past into the
new wonderful glorious future well what
happens when you run out of oppressors
you've got to make them up it goes way
beyond the NASCAR we are living in
make-believe America I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
make believe America is much wider than
just one sports league or much wider
than just one occupied zone of Seattle
it's spreading everywhere we're all
playing cops and robbers over here
before we get into some of those
examples some of my absolute favorite
most ridiculous examples going around
the internet gotta get to the question
we asked yesterday should Jimmy Kimmel
get canceled I felt the best response
most measured response was this one
should we cancel Jimmy Kimmel of course
but not because he wore black face
because he's just not funny that's true
he's not funny he used to be somewhat
funny now he is no longer question for
today I'd love to get your opinion on
should President Trump use force on the
Chaz Choppers of the Soviet Union or
whatever other terms for it you want to
come up with should Trump finally go in
send some force and restore order let me
know I certainly have an opinion on it
but maybe mine is not the most popular
opinion we'll get we'll get to that a
little bit later too we had a race hoax
in NASCAR seems like we have race hoaxes
all the time actually the way that I
knew that Bubba Wallace was not giving
us the whole story is because he managed
to hold his subway sandwich the whole
time while they were investigating his
race car you know when you hold that
subway sandwich that just shows you
something about this this race attack
not quite real but that was not the only
one there was another attack that went
viral earlier today of a man a costing
some woman in her car reducing her to
tears she became very hysterical and
this now went around the internet with
this woman being smeared as a racist but
I think people are drawing the opposite
conclusion from what we really saw so
the setup is that this woman targeted
this man she was racist toward him
whatever that means and so he gets in
her face with the camera you flipped me
off you don't touch me do not touch me
you flipped me off
I don't care why did you flip me off
don't touch me did you ma'am did you or
did you not cuss to me did you know did
you flip me off
why did I get flipped off why did I um
okay so here's the setup obviously this
woman is having a hysterical meltdown
but this guy is causing the hysterical
meltdown what he's saying is you flipped
me off in the road which is something
that happens virtually every time
anybody goes out driving right
someone will flip you off or do punt the
horn or that's that's in the nature of
driving it's recall at road rage call it
whatever it's perfectly normal it's not
some racial incident and so he follows
this woman home she pulls into her
driveway he pulls in behind her gets out
gets a camera in her face that is very
bad behavior that is forget it's not
chivalrous behavior that is aggressive
creepy like if anyone ever did that to
my wife then we're gonna have more than
a YouTube video to worry about kind of
behavior and yet he's being portrayed as
the victim here and he even admits
what's he worried about he's upset
because she flipped him off and so now
he's in her face and she's freaking out
now why is she freaking out she might
just be a hysterical woman but I think
she's probably freaking out because she
knows how this goes how this has been
going for the past few weeks is you have
a viral internet video out of context
accusing some white person of committing
a racism and whether there's evidence
for it or not that person's life is
ruined and the accuser faces no
consequences at all
he actually ironically uses a racial
epithet it's kind of a funny racial
epithet it's one that everyone is using
in popular culture now Karen but Karen
does have a racial quality to it in that
it very specifically refers to a
busybody white woman so he is getting in
her face imagine this imagine what a
what a degenerate man you would have to
be to have a woman becoming hysterical
in front of you a woman that you don't
know and you follow her home and get in
her face and yell insults at her what
did what a sick degenerate pervert
you've got to be to do that so he keeps
this up
she keeps freaking out and having this
this meltdown and then he goes one step
further he decides to Doc's the woman
Karen are you okay explain to me calmly
I'm not attacking you ma'am you flicked
me off guys this is her license-plate
number she lives here this is her
address Karen you flipped me off you cut
me off and flipped me off and now you're
playing the victim ma'am would you like
to calm down guys she flipped me off
she literally flipped me off if she
tried to come home she's carrying Karen
would you like to calm down to have a
conversation why are you okay he
actually is attacking her here I know it
doesn't quite seem that way because
she's obviously becoming very hysterical
she's becoming hysterical for good
reason the people who show up in these
videos get their lives ruined and what
he is saying why here's her license
plate here's where she lives is come get
her come get her mob it would be much
less threatening if he just punched her
in the face and walked away or like that
man in New York threw a firecracker on a
homeless person it would actually be
less threatening because what he's
saying here is here's where she is
here's where you can find her even when
she's in a car here's how you can find
her and you can ruin her life so I
actually think I like to think I would
not react in that way but it's perfectly
understandable that she is just judging
from this incident this guy is a sick
degenerate and I don't know if there are
laws against what he's doing where he is
daxing is against the law in many states
but if there aren't laws then there
should be laws and this guy should be
punished for what he did then you google
him and you find out this guy it's all a
setup it this wasn't because she flipped
him off or anything
he hates white people apparently his his
Twitter handle is why pepo hate why
people hate right yep get it his name is
Carlos Dillard he's pulled this stunt
before he's accused people baselessly of
racism before he's tried to go viral he
considers himself an entertainer and a
comedian and an actor and all sorts of
things he's got all these websites on
the internet and he doesn't have a big
following at all but he's trying to go
viral on Twitter and I guess he did I
guess he did and he got what he wanted
because we're talking about it but of
course we're talking about it because it
trended that's that's what we are that's
what we are creating in this culture is
make-believe there there isn't racial
bigotry going on all over the place
it just isn't happening there isn't a
villain
there isn't an oppressor and so
degenerates like Carlos Dillard have to
make it up we're all making it up in
this culture I don't know I don't even
mean just a single out of him I want to
single him out because he behaved
horribly and should be punished by the
law for it but it's beyond him it's the
whole culture we should all we should
all rewrite reset our culture and yet
that's not happening anytime soon in
fact we're going even further we're now
canceling Eskimo pies you know Eskimo
pies delicious frozen treat they're gone
they're gone we'll get to that one
second we'll get to why they're gone
we'll get to why it's so crazy that
they're gone first I got to thank our
friends over at ero ero
is a solution to a problem that I have
had I'm sure you have had too there's
that one spot in your house that's got
really good Wi-Fi there's that one spine
your hands that is terrible Wi-Fi I
think we all have it it's so frustrating
Eero fixes the problem hero is Wi-Fi
that your home deserves blanketing the
whole place with fast reliable Wi-Fi not
just inside but outside - Iiro extends
your coverage so you can enjoy the nicer
weather and get work done from your deck
II wrote eliminates poor coverage dead
spots buffering you will have a
consistently strong signal wherever you
need it
gyro sets up in minutes plugs right into
your modem or modem router box and you
manage it from a dead simple app I love
it the thing that I love most about Xero
it's so simple to install even I can do
it usually I'm waiting trained like
hours to set things up bit zero two
seconds very easy you can get yours
fixed as soon as tomorrow go to eurocom
slash null scanner wles enter code
knowles at checkout to get free next day
shipping with your order ee ro comm
slash Noel's code knowles at checkout to
get your arrow delivered with free next
day shipping you must use this URL to
receive this offer eurocom slash Noel's
cold Knowles canna wles Eskimo Pie is
gone you can't get an Eskimo Pie anymore
you might be able to get the delicious
treat but it won't be called an Eskimo
Pie why the company that produces it
just sit stated declared we are
committed to being a part of the
solution on racial equality we recognize
that the term Eskimo is derogatory this
move
part of a larger review to ensure our
company and brands reflect our people
values so the premise here is that
Eskimo is a derogatory term it's a slur
but it's not it's not I just googled it
I guess the CEO of the Nestle company
didn't have time to Google this but I
had time to Google this as a matter of
edom ology right the the root of this
word the word Eskimo comes from the Nui
moon word a scheme you meaning a person
who laces a snowshoe it does not have a
pejorative meaning in origin even
Wikipedia admits does not have a
pejorative meaning in origin it's just
some white liberals who decided that
they would be offended on behalf of
Eskimos just like it was white liberals
who decided to get offended on behalf of
Native Americans and and demanded that
the Washington Redskins changed their
name even though the Washington Redskins
nine out of ten Native Americans
surveyed don't care about the Washington
Redskins name just like it was primarily
white liberals pushing to cancel Aunt
Jemima a black character portrayed by a
black model created by a black comedian
we're all just playing make-believe now
not all of the examples of make-believe
America are so frivolous you thought
when you were looking over at Seattle
you thought that those idiots in Chaz
chop-suey mallya you thought that they
were just one-off weirdos they're not
it's not just the strange social
experiment happening within a six-block
radius of Seattle it's spreading
chest is bicoastal now the LARP the
live-action role play is spreading we
now have Chaz and we have has no plans
that's what it is blast no beds that's
what it's very hard to keep all because
they keep changing their name to but I
think it currently is but has the black
house autonomous zone and the black
house autonomous zone is all the way in
Washington DC right across the way from
the White House they've now taken over
and vandalized that historic church
saying
John's Church the President Trump walked
over to and held the Bible up they
vandalized it now they've sprayed their
name be haz on the church and they are
running roughshod over law and order
there with with total impunity you now
have examples in this area of the the
rioters I'm sorry I'm sorry the peaceful
protesters screaming at the cops and the
screams have a racial overtone to them
so in one example you have a black man
yelling at a black woman saying very
insulting things the black man is a
rioter the black woman is a police
officer take a listen to this disgusting
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
so as this dirtbag is spewing this bile
at this woman you can see she's she's
just kind of taking it but she doesn't
seem happy doesn't seem like she's
having a nice time and this is a common
theme I see with all these leftist
protests is it's these dirt bag men
saying vile things to women because I
guess worries about sexism have gone
totally out the window row and they have
gone out the window they've gone out the
window in part actually because of
feminism because of this idea that men
and women are exactly the same and so
men shouldn't treat women in any sort of
special way well they don't they get
violent with them they say disgusting
things to them they've they follow them
to where they park their cars in their
driveway and film them disgusting
disgusting stuff but it takes out an
even weirder racial element when in the
knee they can't do two things at once I
can't fight sexism and racism they got a
I guess they have to pick it's a little
schizophrenic but then in the name of
fighting racism you now have white
leftists screaming at black cops in
defense of black people who they're
screaming at take a listen I have a
question for you you're white and you're
telling this to two black police
officers
you see the problem with that a little
bit oh no I don't because you know what
just because I'm white and I have an
experience racism myself doesn't mean I
can't fight for justice I'm part of the
system no part of the problem just a
sample Act doesn't mean they're not a
part of the problem because I'm white
racism is a white person's problem so
speaking of hysterical women obviously
her argument doesn't make a lot of sense
because they keep moving the goal posts
at one point we're told white people are
not allowed to say anything about this
then we're told that this woman says
basically only white people in this
situation should say anything about it
and we should listen to black people but
then she says we shouldn't listen to
those black people and the key here I
think is autonomous you hear that's the
autonomous zone in Seattle it's the
autonomous zone in Washington this is
why I think it's got a it's has to do
with liberalism itself we all want to be
autonomous liberalism you're always
liberating yourself from the oppressed
you're becoming more and more autonomous
and we are now we've become so liberated
so autonomous we've liberated ourselves
from ourselves so this woman can say
with a straight face that she is
speaking to the black experience in
America with greater knowledge than the
black people that she's screaming it
that we need an autonomous zone within
Washington DC which is a federal zone
within the United States pretty soon
we're gonna have an autonomous zone
within our autonomous so and actually we
already do we have an autonomous zone
within the autonomous zones which are
the segregated zones which they're now
doing on the basis of race there is no
limit to that you will you will never
there will be no limit to the victim
groups this is why as
intersectionalities as progressed on the
Left you've seen it's gone from gay -
gay and lesbian to gay lesbian and
bisexual to gay lesbian bisexual
transgender to LGBTQ then there's a
queue for queer or questioning
LGBTQIA LMNOP it goes on there's no
limit this is why with gender it's gone
from men and women to men and
and intersects to men and women and
intersex and transgender to men and when
256 genders at least that was just at
last count probably there are more now
this will never end and the more we
become autonomous the more we liberate
ourselves it seems the less relation we
have to reality
we've never liberated ourselves into an
autonomous fantasy is trump ever going
to use force against these people is
trump ever gonna restore any order to
the country is trump ever going to
enforce the laws we'll get to that in
one second first though I've got to
thank our friends over at Rock Auto
speaking of doing things yourself and
being autonomous that would be a good
place to be a little more autonomous you
don't have to rely on those brick and
mortar auto parts stores that never have
the parts you need and always charge you
too much they probably order it actually
from Rock Auto then they just double the
price and pass that on to you you can do
that at rockauto.com they have the
lowest price as possible
they don't have constantly changing
prices they're really great the thing I
love about rockauto.com especially for
someone like me I'm not the most handy
guy in the world even I can navigate
their website which is a real compliment
to Rock Auto even I can figure out which
cars I want or which parts rather I want
for my car Rock Auto doc on their family
business too they've been serving online
Auto Parts customers for 20 years which
is more or less the entire history of
the internet head on over to Rock Auto
calm right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck right
Knowles canna wles in their head of your
Bettis box that's most important and
then they will know that we sent you
Rock auto calm and enter Knowles in the
how did you hear Bettis so his Trump
gonna use force President Trump has
finally come out and said that he will
use force against the Black House
autonomous zone he tweeted out he said
there will never be an autonomous zone
in Washington DC as long as I'm your
president if they try they will be met
with serious force now they are trying
and they seem to have succeeded so the
question is this Trump gonna use force
or not use force we might not even be
able to examine the answer to that
question because when Trump tweeted that
Twitter censored the tweet
notice they're doing this more
frequently now Twitter and never
censored any tweets certainly not to
imagine the audacity to censor a tweet
from the president the United States but
they sent out a little notice after they
covered it up they said we've placed a
public interest notice on this tweet for
violating our policy against abusive
behavior specifically the presence of a
threat of harm against an identifiable
group a threat of harm let me translate
that for you into English the top law
enforcement official in the United
States said he would enforce the law
against criminals and Twitter said that
that is abusive and it's a threat of
harm against a group and they can't
tolerate that as far as I'm concerned at
this point we should use any civil legal
means necessary to shred Twitter's
influence in the world get rid of it I
know I enjoy Twitter we all enjoy
Twitter I don't care
bankrupt them break them up take away
their section 230 protections get rid of
them they are actively harming our
country we all have to be on it as long
as it exists because it is the public
square they have them that monopoly on
the public square but they shouldn't we
should get rid of that we cannot I don't
want them to have power I can't take it
anymore with conservatives who say well
I because I'm a conservative I think we
should let some billionaire leftist
socialist tech oligarchs control the
flow of information around our republic
is I'm so conservative no I don't think
that's very conservative and I don't
think they should get protections that
they don't deserve and I don't think
that they should they should be able to
control the public square and that some
unelected jerk tech billionaire ought to
be able to censor the President of the
United States now where did this all
come from it came from a recent action
in Lafayette Park the beginning of the
Black House autonomous zone where
rioters tried to pull down the famous
statue there of Andrew Jackson so
President Trump at this point said I've
authorized the federal government to
arrest anyone who vandalizes or destroys
any monument statue or other such
federal property in the US with up to
ten years in prison for the Veterans
Memorial preserve a
Shack or such other laws that may be
pertinent this action is taken effective
immediately but may also be as retro
actively for destruction or vandalism
already caused there will be no
exceptions I hope that's true I hope we
can believe that I hope every single one
of these rioters rots in prison for a
very long time the way to stop this kind
of madness and violence is to meet it
with force you cannot enforce the law
without using force that's why it's
called law enforcement and right now I
think there's been this game I mean
actually the president admitted it in
his in his rally the other day where he
said look I'm gonna let it burn a little
bit longer I'm gonna let people see what
what democratic government looks like I
understand that because one it means
that you don't need to worry about
sending in force and having another Kent
State on your hands and having people
accuse you of killing innocent
protestors I know what the meetings
going to do but this argument of hey
everybody look at what happens when you
elect Democrats is a little too clever
by half when a Republican occupies the
Oval Office what's the argument elect me
reelect me and then I'll enforce the law
it doesn't work I get I understand why
he's doing it
but it doesn't work I hope he uses force
very quickly because if we don't force
very basic laws and laws where the
president actually does have
considerable influence then what are we
doing what are we fighting for I don't I
don't really know now there is a legal
route there is a way out of the LARPing
sort of there is a way out of the
play-acting but the left is doing right
now and that it was just suggested by it
the founder of B et Black Entertainment
Television Robert Johnson who suggested
that BLM become a formal political party
I've been convinced for a long time that
40 million African Americans who tend to
vote as a bloc in one of the two parties
limit their leverage in getting action
from both parties and I think it's time
that African Americans form an
independent party not be an appendage of
one party or ignored by the other party
and using their leverage in
a democracy to say we stand for things
that are principally focused on the
interests of the 40 million African
Americans and not had that diluted by
trying to be a part of another party
where the interest is the interest may
diverge and oftentimes do diverge
now I give this guy a little bit of
credit because he's taking the political
process much more seriously than just
the rioters and the looters and he's
suggesting something more like what we
see in Europe which is instead of having
the two main parties you have lots of
little parties and lots of more specific
interest groups and they form
coalition's and that will have a
multi-party system I still think it's
LARPing though I still think it's
play-acting because what he says here is
that you've got black voters and they
vote as a bloc either for the Democratic
Party or the Republican Party and that's
not true in so much as black voters vote
as a bloc they vote for Democrats they
don't they don't vote as a bloc for
Republicans and they haven't in many
decades they did at one point they
actually did vote heavily for
Republicans but but they haven't at
least in recent memory so what you would
actually be doing if you created a BLM
political party won the odds that you
actually got buy-in from a significant
portion of black voters for a radical
party like that I think are pretty slim
of what you would in effect be doing is
completely crippling the Democratic
Party if it actually did work the
Democratic Party would fall apart the
Democratic Party needs black voters and
they need virtually all the black voters
and if they lose any of them then
there's in serious trouble
so fine by me now if you want to sort
the BLM party and destroy the Democratic
Party works for me what this is also
presuming is that the black lives matter
party actively represents the majority
of black interests that is not the case
black lives matter does not does not
have very much to do with black lives
mattering black lives matter is
primarily ideological not racial they
are primarily Marxists trained Marxists
the founders of BLM admit that they are
trained Marxists they admit that they're
Marxists in their about Us page on their
website they say that they want to tear
down the nuclear family they call each
other comrade they want to abolish the
police that is not just a ratio
interest party that is a radical Marxist
party exploiting race for for
ideological ends so I I don't think that
is really going to happen either and the
other reason that it's LARPing is it
ties in with the the bigger theme that
we're talking about all all the time
which is it presumes that there is an
anti black white supremacy at work in
America and that's why you need a black
specific political party and that just
isn't the case it just is not the case
the only day you are a racism the only
racism by law that we tolerate racial
discrimination is called affirmative
action and it privileges black and
Hispanic and some other racial
minorities on things like it being
admitted to college or in job
applications and it it disadvantages
white applicants and Asian applicants
which is why Asian students sued Harvard
University because they were
discriminated against on the basis of
their race that's the only one that's
the only racial discrimination on the
books
look around they if there were real
incidence of this then you would see it
but there aren't just a lot of hoaxes
all the way to NASCAR all the way to
Jesse small yay in Chicago and
everywhere in between and so you would
be forming a political party over an
imaginary problem that is probably not
gonna be very successful and I don't
think it's going to happen now there are
some racial issues in the country but
the racial issues are mostly occurring
when there is racial offence given its
given by the left and one of the left's
darlings Oh such a darling he is Jimmy
Kimmel the toast of Hollywood the host
of awards shows is in trouble because he
impersonated a lot of black actors
darkened his skin and used the n-word on
tape and hosted a show called the man
show and made lots of comments that are
now being called called sexist he
offended a lot of leftist sensibilities
so what did he do did he stand firm and
say I'm a comedian I'm telling jokes and
you can't stop me no of course he caved
to the outrage mob is it gonna do him
very well well we'll see well
into that one second we will get into
some of the other make-believe that
we're all playing around in first though
I've got to thank you you people have
gotten me to finally even though I got a
late start beat drew on the YouTube
channel subscriber push not on the daily
wire YouTube channel I mean that's all
well and good but over on my Michael
no-show YouTube channel I think we're
past 75,000 now if you wouldn't mind
would appreciate it if we could get up
to 100,000 you can see a lot of fun
stuff we got breakout separate
interviews bonus segments from the show
also if you're not already a daily wire
member you should consider getting a
reader's pass to daily work on great
value three dollars per month and when
you sign up right now that first month
Qi how much it is one dollar 99 cents
I'm giving it to you good access to the
mobile app articles ad free and premium
content like this latest one from Dru
Biden is a ventriloquist's dummy and the
press knows it and that is certainly
true you get a lot of in-depth analysis
election analysis so head on over daily
wire.com slash subscribe we'll be right
back
Jimmy Kimmel's in trouble
he very famously when he was hosting the
man show put black paint on his face and
played Karl Malone
he said the n-word on joke Christmas
albums in the 1990s he hosted the man
show he got in a lot of trouble so
finally he's addressing this he
conveniently went on vacation a few days
ago as this was all blowing up now he is
apologizing sort of but pay attention to
this apology I have long been reluctant
to address this as I knew doing so would
be celebrated as a victory by those who
are quite apologies with weakness and
cheers for leaders who use prejudice to
divide us
so already he's accusing his opponents
of being racists that delay was a
mistake there was nothing more important
to me than your respect and I apologize
to those who were genuinely hurt or
offended by the makeup I wore were the
words I spoke on k-rock radio in the mid
90s I did a recurring impression of the
NBA player Karl Malone in the late 90s I
continued impersonating Malone on TV we
hired makeup artists to make me look as
much like Karl Malone as possible I
never considered that this might be seen
as anything other than an imitation of a
fellow human being one that had no more
to do with coral skin color than it did
with his bulging muscles and bald head
pause there what he's saying is oh I
didn't even think about the race I
wasn't wearing blackface I was doing him
an impersonation of a black person which
involves darkening my skin I buy that
argument I totally buy that argument you
know who else made that argument megyn
kelly they were debating when megyn
kelly went over to network TV she had
left Fox she went to network and they
were discussing what blackface is and
she said well you know when I was a kid
here I'll find the exact quote when I
was a kid that was okay as long as you
were dressing up as like a character say
not not that you would be mocking an
entire race but if you were gonna go for
Halloween as Diana Ross for instance you
darkened your skin you're going as a
character that was fine she said the
same exact thing that Jimmy Kimmel said
here except she was fired only for
making
was comments so jimmy kimmel now had to
apologize because he actually wore the
stuff he did all the impressions he said
the n-word on tape did this for many
years and his apology the reason that
Jimmy Kimmel will likely be able to keep
his job his apology is the very same
thing that megyn kelly said that got her
fired because there's no fairness here
there's no standard Jimmy Kimmel bends
the knee you know back in the day Jimmy
Kimmel was somewhat funny Jimmy Kimmel
used to make kind of off-color racy
jokes and they're funny as as jokes tend
to be funny right I mean that's that's
what comedy is comedy is not milquetoast
approved politically correct stuff it
pushes boundaries and sometimes he
pushes boundaries on sex sometimes it
pushes boundaries on race sometimes it
pushes boundaries on food I don't know
on any sort of topic right so he used to
be funny when he wasn't afraid of the
woke PC mob now he bent the knee you
think the mob is gonna be satisfied
maybe maybe they will they do protect
their own sometimes but it's gonna be a
little tricky because the mob has just
found out just like they just discovered
this k-rock album where he said the
n-word a bunch of times which has been
out there for years they just found out
the Jimmy hosted the man show which is
the thing that I know him best from
because it was on TV on Comedy Central
when I was a kid give you a sense was
the man show the man show was kind of a
tongue-in-cheek self-effacing view of
what men are so portray men is kind of
just like fat slobs who just want to
drink beer and look at hot women wearing
bikinis and things like that the intro
actually just featured a bunch of girls
jumping on trampolines
[Music]
[Music]
obviously very tongue-in-cheek kind of
introduction I was a funny show it's
kind of a low-budget show in the nights
are very good it was Jimmy Kimmel and
Adam Carolla they did good work on their
one bit that they did on that show for
the most famous bit from the whole show
is they they held a petition outside and
it was a petition against women's
suffrage so and the idea being that
people didn't know what the word
suffrage meant they thought it was like
suffering or something so they would get
women and liberal man to sign this sign
this petition to end women's suffrage
how long is this gonna go on
ladies unite against suffrage in the
suffrage Inc now we're trying to stop
the suffrage and the suffrage of women
in this country thank you very much I'd
use for personal reasons my mother two
of my aunts and my sister all suffrage
last year is the 19 the man it's very
unjust the minutes very unjust
it's the amendment that gives women the
right to vote it's not as though this
were a drama this is not a serious chess
isn't a news broadcast it's a comedy
show it's a joke does anybody really
believe that Jimmy Kimmel is sorry for
telling these jokes no does anybody
really believe that anybody's offended
by those jokes no we're all just playing
pretend by the way I don't think we
should defend Jimmy Kimmel here I think
we have unilaterally disarmed far too
long Jimmy Kimmel has become a total
left-wing hack didn't used to be but now
he is and I think we've we've got to
stop playing by a completely different
set of rules than the left plays by when
you're in a battle that your opponent
gets a say and it
it is simply surrender to to not be
willing to actually engage in those
those rules but it is pretend don't kid
yourself it is pretend think about
Howard Stern he's another guy who used
to be shocking and now he's the toast of
Hollywood totally caved to the left no
comedian including Jimmy Kimmel has
sucked up to Hollywood more in recent
years than Howard Stern he used to be
the anti Hollywood he used to make fun
of celebrities now he's their best
friends now he goes to their weddings so
Howard Stern just got a little trouble
same reason Jimmy Kimmel did they caught
him on tape years and years ago during a
bit using in the n-word as part of a
comedy routine so Jimmy was confronting
me Fortius like Howard was confronted
about this on the view and Howard
completely denied it you use the n-word
a lot wait a second hold on from the Ku
Klux Klan yes very freely use the n-word
and my belief was hey say it out in the
open yeah I didn't use the n-word let's
be very clear okay let's be very clear
that that isn't what happened actually
what happened is Howard Stern put on
actual blackface he wasn't just
pretending to be some other guy he put
on actual blackface with the white all
around his lips and he he used the
n-word multiple times now there's there
is more to this sketch which we'll talk
about at the end but take a listen to
this Robin what does you call a black
rocket scientist you can say whatever
you want you're smelling will be rode
dad dad you didn't know I was gonna say
that
Whoopi had no chance to write it I don't
accept that kind of language you can
call her whatever you want but you don't
talk to me that way or I'll leave well
don't let the door hit you on your big
black ass my mind a way out of it
now where was I oh yes now what there
you is a filthy so that's a little
different than the way Howard Stern
presented it on the view right and yet
what is actually going on here for those
of you who weren't just listening but
who have actually seen this sketch
two of the three performers in this
sketch are black one of them is Robin
Quivers who was longtime sidekick on the
Howard Stern Show and the other one is
Sherman Hemsley who plays George
Jefferson one of the most famous black
comedic actors of the 20th century and
she referred to him as Ted well white
because Howard Stern wasn't playing
Howard Stern Howard Stern was playing
Ted Danson Ted Danson a white liberal
great great actor love Ted Danson but he
had this infamous moment where he wore
blackface at an event and his defense
was that he was dating Whoopi Goldberg
very much black who was also at the
event and so when Howard Stern was doing
was a sort of satire of Ted Danson
performing a racist routine in front of
Whoopi Goldberg and using Whoopi
Goldberg's blackness as an excuse for
doing the routine or at many levels to
this does anybody think that Howard
Stern is a racial bigot and was actually
doing racism no the sketch was actually
a sketch making fun of racism and making
fun of excuses for racism although
actually on that does anyone think that
Ted Danson's are racist no he was dating
Whoopi Goldberg that actually was the
excuse it's all just make-believe and
yet could you imagine if that were a
conservative would you imagine if it
were steven crowder who did that bit he
would not be permitted in polite society
he would not be permitted anywhere so
what are we doing out of Howard Stern I
don't I think comedy that's fine tell
jokes don't bother me
doesn't bother me when comedians tell
jokes if they go too far they'll lose
their audience but to gin up this
astroturf campaign you've got to be
canceled no more that is pretend it's
all pretend and yet we have to let them
follow the logic of their own ideology
we've got to let them get to the end of
this we can't stand in the way
we can't play by a different set of
rules it's sad though
because what it means is none of this is
serious and our culture is no longer
serious Eve another example in Oregon
right now there's a mask order you know
you got out because of the virus
remember the virus I mean either you've
now got to wear a mask in public but not
if you're black I'm serious
Lincoln County Oregon health officials
announced last week all residents must
wear face coverings when they're in
public places if they're likely to come
within six feet of other people who are
who are not of their own household but
people of color do not have to follow
the new rule if they're worried about
racial profiling which means I first I
can tell that means there are two
options the whole idea with the masks is
that the corona virus is SuperDuper
deadly and SuperDuper contagious we're
all gonna die from it so you gotta you
gotta wear the masks everywhere you go
so two options this I say one corona
virus is not SuperDuper deadly right
because they're saying some people don't
have to wear the masks and white
supremacy is not a real thing because
people of color which is a new term but
as the term everyone has to use now I
guess that that group of people gets a
special privilege that the white people
don't get they don't have to wear the
masks all the time but the white people
do by threat of law so either
coronavirus not it's been a little bit
hyped and there's no such thing as white
supremacy or coronavirus is super duper
deadly like they're all telling us all
the health experts and there definitely
is white supremacy and maybe this county
in Oregon is being run by the Ku Klux
Klan or something because they're saying
yeah black people don't wear the masks
good luck with the virus I don't know I
to me it seems more likely that it's the
former situation that the media have
actually just been lying to us this
whole time and exaggerating things this
whole time than it is that there's this
awful racist anti black policy going on
in Oregon nevertheless but those are the
options either way somebody is playing
pretend Ben Stiller and Stiller a name I
did not think would be involved in
today's show but but he has injected
himself into these debates because as
the statues are coming down of
Washington Jefferson Columbus they took
down a statue of Teddy Roosevelt
at the museum that only exists because
of Teddy Roosevelt in New York and what
Ben Stiller suggested is it's good yet
take down Teddy Roosevelt and replace
him with a statue of Robin Williams
Robin Williams playing Teddy Roosevelt
in that movie it's that movie Night at
the Museum I think now it's just a
little joke from Ben Stiller but the
joke tells you a lot about our culture
right now we don't want the real thing
we can't handle the real thing we can't
handle the real debates we can't handle
the real problems we can't handle the
real eternal political questions we
can't handle the real facts of our
history we can't handle any of that we
can only handle the make-believe that
pretend the cartoon the the joke that's
what that's all it's funny we can't
handle jokes either we our culture has
become a joke and that's what we have
that's it we we are we are now a country
that tears down statues of Teddy
Roosevelt and would prefer to erect
statues of clowns playing Teddy
Roosevelt I think we may be may be
becoming a nation of clowns ourselves
and I'm at least glad that we're we're
getting this part right I open the show
and I said there's just something in a
liberalism that seems to to be like a
ticking time bomb almost because you're
always you're always liberating yourself
from the oppressive past so the past
always has to be bad no matter how good
times are in liberalism you've got to
have a kind of antipathy for the past
because now we're so much freer and more
liberated in autonomous and emancipated
and that goes on and on and on
progressively until you get to some
utopian future and I think a lot of
people that even conservatives think
that the time we're living in right now
it's the best time or the best were the
smartest we're the most moral we are the
most humane and we've got iPhones for
goodness sakes we have iPhones oh man
are we so much better than those dumb
old-timey people our ancestors who came
before us great story
challenges that assumption kind of a sad
story but it's funny nonetheless there's
a painting in Spain this painting
by the baroque painter bitola mae
esteban maria it's a painting of the
Virgin Mary and the painting needed to
be restored so the owner of this
painting went to an amateur painting
restorer and so he said can you can you
fix up the painting the first attempt
was absolutely disastrous completely
destroyed the painting it took this
beautiful baroque painting of the
Blessed Virgin and turned it into what
looks like a third graders assignment so
then they tried again made it look like
a first writers assignment it got worse
then they tried again and it looks like
a three-year-old finger painted it they
took a beautiful work of art from
hundreds of years ago and made it worse
and then worse and then worse that's not
progress that would be the opposite of I
would be regressed I believe and this
has happened before actually in Spain
again there's a fresco of Jesus in 2012
and an amateur painter this woman
Cecilia Jimenez attempted to restore the
etch a Omo painting and the same same
results I mean it just became this
blotchy mess they took a beautiful
painting and then and then just turned
it into what what could be finger paint
that's the perfect encapsulation of our
culture that's what we are doing we're
tearing down great men we're tearing
down works of art now one of the black
lives matter lead activists is calling
for people to smash stained-glass
windows and statues and and icons at
churches and that is happening at least
in Europe I don't know if it's happened
yet in America I guess they did to face
that they tried to burn it down and then
to face the st. John's Church all of
this is happening and we're
congratulating ourselves all the
beautiful art all the beautiful culture
all the beautiful political system all
the beautiful civilization we are
tearing it to shreds lighting it on fire
all on the premise that we're so much
better than the people who built it
we're so much better
watch us torch it and yet the people who
are doing it are so divorced from
reality they are so lost in their own
make believe in their own fantasy that
they can't even
they think that that actually reality is
the opposite of what it is they think up
is down good is bad and and law is
lawlessness and on and on and on we're
living in an upside-down world and
something tells me that just like that
painting restoration things are gonna
get worse and worse and worse and I hope
one day they get better but for the near
future I think I mentioned this
yesterday the only way out is going to
be through by the way speaking of
terrible news there is not going to be
any show tomorrow because I am going to
take a quick little jaunt to Washington
DC I want to throw my hat in the ring to
become the president of the be has the
autonomous zone there we'll see if it
works out otherwise I'll have to come
back maybe I'll run against come holler
or something in California but I will be
back on Friday so stay stay tuned
tomorrow stay safe stay put I'll see you
on Friday I'm Michael Knowles is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies executive producer Jeremy Boren
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin fenders
hair and makeup nikka geneva production
assistant ryan love the michael knowles
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20 if you prefer
facts over feelings aren't offended by
the brutal truth and you can still laugh
at the insanity filling our national
news cycle well tune in to the ben
shapiro show we'll get a whole lot of
that and much more see you there